so when we talk about how the left
really believes in their own under moral
superiority i mean they really believe
it it's really funny to watch their
attitude toward vaccines because most of
last year the idea from the left was
that any vaccine developed under trump
was unreliable and then for years before
that in places like california the idea
was that woo crystals were going to save
you from things like measles mumps and
rubella now however trump is out of
office and the democrats say their
vaccines are good so vaccines are good
not only that if you're somebody who did
not take the vacs it must be that you
are essentially a nazi that is the case
that jimmy kimmel was making on his show
last night his team produced an a fake
commercial from mattel
anti-vax barbie and of course it turns
out that anti-vax barbie does not have
natural immunity or any serious
questions about transmissibility it
turns out that anti-vax barbie is just a
nazi because this is what people on the
left think of their political opponents
you know there's so much stuff
to sell to these anti-vouchers and the
folks at mattel are no dummies they made
a minto for christmas with a twist on
what pro is probably america's all-time
favorite doll
there's a new doll in town and the fun
is contagious it's anti-vaxx barbie
she's strong she's independent she
doesn't trust science
bill gates is the antichrist that she's
have satan's blood
barbie comes with a computer so she can
do her own research says here madonna
turns your teeth jewish take your
barbies everywhere
shopping i'm sorry you can't come in
here without a mask i have a medical
condition
okay pause it there for a second so
again the the entire idea here is that i
mean every single objection here is
crazy right if if you said i have
natural immunity barbie that obviously
wouldn't have the same effect so the
idea here from jimmy kimmel is that
every single person who has not taken a
vaccine believes that
the that bill gates is putting
microchips in the vaccine or that it
turns your quote-unquote teeth jewish
because you're actually a secret nazi
also i'm noticing that in this little
play-acted skit in which the the
anti-massacre walks into a storm is
asked to put on the mask it is the
anti-masker who goes crazy most of the
videos i've seen are kind of the
opposite most of the videos that i have
seen are people who walk into a store
not wearing a mask and a person starts
screaming at them and yelling at them
that's typically what i have seen it's
also what i've experienced i mean i
recently was on a flight from new jersey
to to florida
and on that flight i was eating some
popcorn and the stewardess came by and
she looks at me and she goes you need to
put up your mask between bites between
bites that's gonna save us all between
bites
you know the people who are
authoritarian here are generally not the
people who are who are against masking
most of the people who are authoritarian
are the the crazed pro masters in any
case the propaganda continues and again
the idea here is is from jimmy kimmel
captain understanding and empathy that
everyone who he opposes politically is
in fact a disciple of either adolf
hitler or alex jones or both
and you're going to jail to the stables
thank you for sharing your medicine
dancer he's on the plane
and the only mandate this barbie cares
about is with her proud boyfriend ken hi
ken want to go throw eggs at nurses
sorry babe can't hear you alex jones is
talking about monoglobal antibodies
there it is all righty stop it right
there that okay again monoclonal
antibodies are good
when did monoclonal antibodies become
bad i mean that's
they're they're bad now even though joe
biden has pushed them also if you are a
let's go brandon advocate like you think
joe biden is doing a bad job this means
that you are an anti-i wonder why uh
there is no racial diversity among the
anti-vaxxed barbies here considering how
many black americans are not vast at
this point in time
like i've noticed that it's only the
people that jimmy kimmel wishes to to
castigate who appear in this again the
only reason i'm taking this even
remotely seriously is because jimmy
kimmel is a joke jimmy kimmel is the
woke pope of late night comedy who's
violated every stricture of wokeness but
has somehow survived because he's a lap
dog for the democratic party
uh on a pure humor level i'm just
wondering what makes this funny
like it's not subtle it's not
interesting
it's it's just a bunch of screed
headlines taken directly from slate
and then plopped into a barbecue okay
but i guess we're supposed to pretend
that this guy is funny we'll get to more
on this in just one moment first using
the internet without expressvpn well
that's like leaving your laptop exposed
at the coffee shop table while you run
to the restroom most of the time
probably fine but what if one day you
come out and there's just some weird guy
who's looking at all of your emails or
even worse your laptop is just gone well
here's the thing if you are leaving all
of your information exposed that is a
problem and this is why you need a vpn
every time you connect to an unencrypted
network cafes hotels airports any hacker
on the same network can gain access to
your personal data passwords financial
details etc hackers can make up to a
thousand bucks per person selling
personal information on the dark web so
why should you use expressvpn well
number one it is super easy to use like
check this out right okay so i just open
up my phone you can see the expressvpn
app is right there i open it up not
connected but i wish to be protected and
so i hit that button and now it says
connected and now i'm protected and it
is indeed that simple it is super secure
it would take a hacker with a super
computer over a billion years to get
past express vpn's encryption you can
fire up the app click one button get
protected phones laptops tablets and
more you can stay secure on the go i
care about my personal information this
is why i use expressvpn you should do
the same secure your online data today
by visiting expressvpn.com
ben shapiro show that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
ben shapiro show and you can get an
extra three months for free
expressvpn.com ben shapiro show
speaking of propagandas msnbc
now has a new weekend host you ready for
this who is it who is it
simone sanders so simone sanders went
directly from being a press secretary
for bernie sanders to being a press
secretary for kamala harris to having a
show on msnbc now imagine if sean spicer
had left the trump administration and
immediately been granted a weekend show
on fox news or kaylee mccanady had left
the trump administration and given a
full-on weekend show on fox news a lot
of people have been like well that seems
kind of proper propagandistic does it
not but apparently if simone sanders
does it it's good and right and decent
i'm never going to get over the fact
that the media have somehow turned
george stephanopoulos an actual hillary
clinton press secretary into
in a a in a political news anchor it's
just insane to me
according to variety.com she's the
latest personality to join the nbc
universal backs cable news outlet under
a new top executive rashida jones as
executives seek to gain traction in new
media spaces while facing turnover among
some of the network's most familiar
personalities
going from the vicinity of the white
house to a tv news gig is a well-trod
path for prominent white house aides
that's the journey made by former trump
administration advisers larry kudlow and
kaylee mcinerney when they move to fox
news channel mcinnany i believe is a
regular guest and kudlow had been a tv
personality before he went back to fox
news
others like george stephanopoulos and
nicole wallace have become fixtures for
viewers at abc news and msnbc by the way
notice the differentiation here george
stephanopoulos is perceived as
quote-unquote objective larry kudlow and
kaylee mcinning are not
but says
simone sanders i wanted to be at a
network that had an already established
record in the streaming world and would
have a show on streaming and on linear
and that and one that wasn't just an
experiment
apparently a bunch of msnbc's newer
hosts including eddie hassan and i'm in
mo yeldon also lead shows that appear on
both the cable news network as well as
the choice from msnbc which is an outlet
on the streaming video hub again the the
revolving door they should honestly just
forget about the revolving door and just
give jen saki a show she was on cnn
before she was in the obama
administration before that why not just
skip the middleman does she really need
to leave the white house to just be
given a show
on the air
i
why i mean just just get rid of the
entire veil and just make it clear that
the msnbc team is a reflection of the
white house
why does there have to be some sort of
of iron curtain between working at msnbc
and working at the white house
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed